hello and welcome to a special edition
of spectator TV I'm Katie balls and I'm
joined by Fraser Nelson and we have just
had Boris Johnson's evidence session to
the Privileges committee there were a
few things to note in what was quite a
lengthy session around four hours a few
breaks for going for votes but I think
just to run through a few highlights
before we discuss them Fraser and we had
Boris Johnson explaining that it was
essential there are drinks um in the
form of leaving do at one point in order
to make sure relations weren't
acrimonious it was necessary because two
senior members of Staff the uh effective
chief of staff and the director of
communications had both left the
building or were about to leave the
building in pretty acrimonious
circumstances or what were potentially
acrimonious circumstances it was
important for me to be there and to give
reassurance you declined to repeat some
of the claims in the Press by supporters
of him that the the Privileges committee
amounts to a kangaroo court have you
characterized us as a kangaroo call you
can tell by my presence this afternoon
by the seriousness with which I have
taken your questions uh by my attempts
to answer in detail uh what you the
points you've you've put to me how
seriously I take you and your committee
and he said with hindsight he realized
that that Infamous bring your own booze
party in the garden would not have
looked so good if someone had looked
over the wall at the time I can't say I
think he was concerned about the
impression that people might gain if
they looked Over the Garden Wall if they
were coming from the uh the the media
room and thought that we were doing
something that other people weren't
allowed to do and I in my opening
um remarks I made clear that I can see
why people might have felt that way
you've been watching the sessions
were you impressed by either side Boris
Johnson or the committee it was quite a
depressing spectacle on every angle
actually you had Harry Harmon the
chairman very much getting into her
dramatic role as the judge here setting
her up was a great lengthy Prelude and
talking about the importance of Truth in
Parliament Etc and then very very
quickly gets down in the weeds and what
did you know and why who does it and
it's quite easy just to lose track of
this
um and of course it's strange to see so
much attention here you've got all the
parliaments watching this the the
televisions have cleared three or four
hours for it all on whether Boris
Johnson knowingly misled the house he's
admitted but he misled the house he's
lost his job as a result of it he had to
quit in disgrace so there's no the
punishment has come he's now
um game over for him as a politician and
yet this is now becoming one of the most
dramatic political moments of the year
so far what's he and there's not we
didn't even learn anything new I think
boy Johnson himself pointed out that in
10 months the committee hadn't managed
to find a shred of evidence to
contradict his claim that when he said
that all rules were being observed he
didn't know anything to the country and
if you know Boris you know that's
probably quite likely because he
operates in this sort of buffer zone of
vagueness where he always wants
plausible deniability he's done this
throughout his life in politics and even
before that he likely he likes to not
get into trouble by pretending he didn't
really know what was going on in the
first place so it's completely plausible
that this sort of this cloud of
confusion will strategically assembled
around him through most of his time in
number 10 with pretty bad consequences
for the country but it does help him
claim no knowledge now
as you say
shall Revelations and that's session
because in part so much this is covered
during the time I think at one point uh
one of Boris Johnson's defenses was well
everyone keeps talking about the
birthday party which is what he was
fined for but that originally was
uncovered not by the mirror or ITV as
part of partygate but was an
introduction to a Saturday times read
and it was used as a little bit of color
about what was going on the pandemic
response as evidence in Boris Johnson's
mind that well cleared people didn't
think they were doing too much wrong
because because it was briefed a soft
color but we did have evidence put
forward before the session started and
yesterday Boris Johnson's evidence and
his defense and then this morning I
think a few trickier things so you have
Simon case the top civil servant
the league of top civil servant perhaps
there's a better way to put it and
ultimately saying that he he didn't uh
tell Boris Johnson or guidance had been
followed you have Jack Doyle his former
director of communications raising
similar concerns and then you have uh
Martin Reynolds who at the time I think
has had the nickname party Marty over
the bring your own booze party
um saying that when it came to what
Boris Johnson said in the house which is
ultimately what this all comes to the
statements Boris Johnson made in the
House of Commons where he said all the
rules and guidance had been followed
that he had advised Boris Johnson not to
say that and he had done so regardless
so that's probably the you know the
trickier claims which is if Boris Jones
wants to talk about all their you know
the fact that no one told him
specifically listened he was following
the advice of his close team there are
members of his close team who seem to
dispute or at least question this idea
that he was being told everything was
okay all the time
um but did you get a sense of a Smoking
Gun today
not proving his guilt no there was lots
to cast out in his version of events but
when you look at what the tests the
committee has to come up with here can
they be confident so confident that they
would risk
um suspending it from Parliament and
perhaps kicking him out as an NP can't
really be that confident that he lied
when he said he didn't no
certainly for all the things you
mentioned you can very much doubt air
that Boris was really confident to say
that there wasn't one but again you come
back to the vagueness and again his
strategic vagueness so I think it's
going to be quite difficult for a
majority in that committee to rule that
they are clear that Boris Johnson
knowingly misled the house I'd simply
there's no evidence to point to all
you've got is your gut feeling now what
were so many things that annoy me about
this and the most annoying thing is I
just think the whole thing is so trivial
compared to the things which we should
be discussing and we've got a cover
story in the expected murder for example
that there are 140 000 pupils now
effectively absent from school after
lockdown where's the debate about that
and people seem very uninterested in Far
some really important issue now we all
know that Boris Johnson misled the House
of Commons we all know that his
officials were making these rules were
breaking them themselves and so in a way
it seems to be a huge amount of
attention over something which is first
of all relatively trivial and secondly
um probably is not going to lead
anywhere anyway because there's no
evidence suggesting that he um that he
knowingly misled the house but then
again when I was looking at it now and
again because it got so ridiculous you
were almost tempted to feel sorry for
him but then you have to remember all of
the people who were basically arrested
and fined due to his ridiculous rules in
the first place the pensioners who were
him find 200 pounds for eating a bag of
chips and a laundrette the um women who
were at least coming after them for
having a cup of coffee when went for a
walk together tens of thousands of
offenses during these ridiculous rules
and people were not able to say to the
police as Boris Johnson is saying now
our visit get out clause because of this
that and the other what we saw through
that this was
perhaps what I regard as the biggest
outrage about lockdown for those of you
know there was always a get out clause
there was always oh this is a work
function for example take you seeing
what we're leaving do it was absolutely
essential he's saying that I gathered my
staff to salute
um somebody who was leaving it's the
customs of these islands that we raise a
glass and toast somebody who's leaving
the party it was necessary from as a
leader to raise morale amongst the staff
all of these things were true but he
made it illegal for anybody else to do
that so him claiming that it was
essential that he was to have a living
dude to raise morale it's not that I
disagree with him I think if any serious
things are essential that anybody else
who had done that would have had the
police come after him thanks to his
rules and when you remember that you do
tend to think to yourself well in this
case he does deserve everything he's
getting I think it was another reminder
of some of the evidence Boris Johnson
gave um so when he was talking about the
bring your own booze party saying at the
time you have to understand it just did
not cross my mind I just thought this
was a work event and lots of people
laugh and says you know that's
ridiculous there were Trestle tables so
lots of people are stands you know
they've got the Marius things probably
anyone's doing them in the country on
that day and but then you look at from a
different perspective and I don't mean
this to make excuses for Boris Johnson
particularly but if you're working in
number 10 you had such a different
experience than the rest of the country
when it comes to lockdown well for a
startup they were all in the office
exactly lots of people never really
spent a day at home and they were seeing
their colleagues I've spoken to people
who are working in number 10 who felt in
a way they had this separate bubble it
was almost a number 10 bubble where you
know it was different rules because they
were seeing each other so frequently so
many of them had had covered themselves
they felt as though they had immunity
but of course every time you hear this
you just go back to the point but you
you didn't make it so if someone had
covered they could go out and do things
so why would that uh you know it was
different rules
um so so I think that would potentially
even if you don't agree with the logic
um work in Boris Johnson's favor for
that people did just see things quite
differently and but I think it's also
the case when you're looking at this
approachment which clearly was you know
box office today it's going to be in
papers all of tomorrow but it does feel
I mean this committee was first raised
when Boris Johnson was prime minister so
if this was taking place when Boris
Johnson was still in number 10 I think
it'd be much more high stakes obviously
instead I think lots of and you'll see I
think in Tory activist polling you know
there is a sense some people think Boris
Johnson has had punishment enough now
committee lots of MPS will say it's not
about punishment it's about truth it's
about what ministers are expected to do
and but I think the circumstances that
this has now come to be in as a result
of you know the fact he was pushed out
Liz trust never she neck means that it
just doesn't it feels it just doesn't
feel as though it has the same weight as
it would have done otherwise and you do
begin to wonder what happens if the
committee fights against Boris Johnson
and recommends a long suspension because
of course they recommend a suspension of
10 days or 10 sitting days then he's
vulnerable to a recall petition there
could be a by-election do you think
there'd be um anger at that point
towards Boris Johnson or sympathy do you
think he'd lose the suit or there's no
doubt about it if you get suspended for
10 days there will be recompetition and
labor will fight it like a general
election now as you write in your
political column Katie the embarrassing
thing is that Russia sunec would really
have to go out there and campaign for
Boris Johnson to stay and it would be a
humiliation for the conservatives so
it's part of Labor strategy right now to
hang the lockdown parties around
Russia's next neck this is why it's so
strategically important for Harry at
home and then everyone else in the labor
party to make as much as they can about
saying you know that's not ancient
history this is the conservative party
the one standing for election next year
are going to be the ones who locked you
all down and had lots of parties
themselves so they want to do everything
they can to make Boris Johnson not Asian
history but a current Tory Saga that's
why it all depends on the four um Tories
in that committee only seven members of
them so four Tories can effectively uh
veto if they were to vote together and
now there's lots of guessing as to where
they they are we know that many of them
are not great fans of of Boris Johnson
and but then again would they really
want to knowing as they do if they give
them a 10-day suspension then they will
be humiliating defeat for the party
that's likely to follow pretty quickly
um so this is and the more the more when
I saw today is um I actually did wonder
if there would be some Smoking Gun if
there's evidence we've come up with
something that would prove what we need
to prove that he knew he absolutely knew
that um there were parties when he said
there weren't absent any such evidence
you would need pretty strong animus
towards Boris Johnson to say that no
probability he was actively telling a
lie and you would also need for those
four conservatives because let's not
pretend they're all neutral here I mean
they know they're they're all I'm I
forget if all four of them are fighting
their seats again at the next election
but if they are it's not within their
interests forever Tory party to go
through the debacle of losing a former
prime minister and having labor
triumphant and Boris Johnson's old seat
so I I now reasonably sure that the
committee will not find for to give him
a 10-day suspension they might give him
a seven day or they might not even give
them anything at all but if there are
seven MPS four of them are Tories and
they lack that Smoking Gun evidence as
we've seen today
the process can be very damaging for in
the process can be very
um embarrassing for the conservatives
but I think they will stop short of
inflicting on themselves the blow of
losing a former prime minister
yeah I think if you did get to that
by-election point um so these MPS
decided to go for to go for a 10-day
suspensional to me that is potentially
lose the surveys you like either way
because say Boris Johnson somehow pulls
out the bag and wins that by-election
you can just imagine how that's going to
Galvanize his supporters who will say we
told you was he was an election winner
look at all there's no runs of um you
know by-election defeats and now look
look what Boris Johnson has done and
then if he loses it uh Rishi Scenic will
probably be accused of not putting
enough funds into defending the seat and
Boris Johnson could be pitchers of
brexit Martyrs I mean the establishment
pushed out because they didn't like him
so I you could sense that in number 10
at least I think um avoiding that would
be preferable not they have a direct say
in it and the other news just finally
today Fraser
um relates to rishi's next brexit deal
well and actually his tax return that's
trying to ratchet free both very quickly
um so so I suppose actually before we
get to the brexit deal and viciousness
obviously said he's a politician of
integrity and but he also still has
learned some of the key tricks of the
trade which is get out potentially bad
news when there's a lot going on so
there is uh we found it today that
around 4 P.M Rishi Cena would be
releasing his tax return so he's
promised to do it's taken quite a long
time to do
um obviously right in the middle of
Boris Johnson's evidence
um did anything strike you about it I
didn't expect well obviously we know
that if an MP earns money he has to
declare it so a tax return shouldn't
tell you if an MP is earning lots of
money on the side that should be
impossible under our system but what I
didn't work out was that Richardson Oak
was so incredibly wealthy in his own
right that him simply buying and selling
shares every year would give him in this
case a profit of 1.6 million pounds if
that's simply him keeping his portfolio
from from day to day for two years
running he made
um capital gains of that amount of
course he paid full tax on it but we all
know that his wife is richer than the
king and and that's sort of famous and
the impression is that that Rishi
married into this insanely wealthy
family but no no set her aside Rishi
sunec would be the richest man in his
own right ever to sit I think in 10
Downing streets because of the
incredible amount of money he must have
earned before he came into parliaments
in 2010 and just as the final item we
have a situation where the Windsor
framework is finally voted on it was a
rebellion just over 20 Tory MPS voted
against it I think around 48 Tory MPS
abstained now depending who you speak to
this was a huge successor of Russia's
new neck and to be fair to Richard
Scenic there were warnings I think in
February saying up to a hundred Tory MPS
could actively vote against any deal on
the protocol but the European research
group have done their own analysis and
they said well you count the abstentions
as no votes then the Tory work majority
would go if every opposition MP voted
against it though I think on the numbers
today the Tories would still have been
fine
um do you think that's a decent result
for rishis unit I think you'd be quite
pleased yes I mean he the rebels were
not the usual crowds you heard three
former Party leaders
Boris Johnson this trust in Duncan Smith
so a pretty Patel there was an All-Star
cast Jake Barry yeah people who know
this is an egg so looking at that you're
trying to work out is there a new
awkward Squad here
but I can't quite to me it looked like a
lot of sort of retired Grandes I mean
IDs for example almost certainly won't
be in Parliament of the next election
um so other than Jake Berry I couldn't
see much of a growing kind of anti-sync
squad there I think he'd be quite
pleased that it was only 20. this was a
really controversial piece of
legislation even the dup and voted
against it and if a dep voted against it
once upon a time you would have thought
well in that case a whole bunch of Tory
and brexiteers are going to vote against
it out of solidarity with the dep if
that didn't really happen
um so all told I think this is looking
to be quite a good week for Rishi sunak
not only it is he incredibly wealthy but
his political position of the party is
quite secure because if you did want to
get rid of him you would vote against
him now to destabilize him on a
signature deal would be a major way of
weakening him and only 20 of his MPS
less than 10 chose to do that things
thank you Fraser thank you for watching